robin if you're talking to us you're not
you're you're you're muted
welcome everybody to rush district
council's remote
meeting of the extraordinary council on
the 8th of september 2020
and welcome also to anybody watching
this via the live stream
i will now take item one on the agenda
apologies for absence
we have seized apologies in the office
from councillors mrs hoy
mr hoy george ionu mike wilkinson
and councillor burton are there any
others members
uh chairman um mike lucas gill was
having terrible problems getting
with his broadband so you keep trying
throughout the evening but other than
that gives his apologies
thank you okay i shall now take item
agenda item 2 to receive declarations of
interest members are there any
declarations of interest
that's quick councillor arthur williams
thank you chairman i'm not sure whether
i need to um
[Music]
interest on the fact that i am a member
of rocha parish council and some of the
assets are in the russia parish council
award
thank you thank you councillor wilson
that will be
councillor williams that will be noted
council lumley
thank you chairman um i believe i should
declare an interest you're muted
council alumni
apologies i need to declare an interest
as
one of the trustees or one of the
partner organizations involved in
tonight's asset programme
thank you council alumni any others
pearson
councillor mcpherson
thank you chairman non-pecuniary i'm i'm
vice
chairman of rochester parish council and
again some of the assets are within our
parish
thank you thank you councillor mcpherson
council spent
council sparing
on on the basis that uh members of
rochester parish council i'm a member
of brady town council and assets
involved in this
evening's meeting are within the radi
district
chairman if i may
council award thank you chairman for the
same reason
uh that has been said i'm a member of
raley town council
and because it is within uh our area i
better declare an interest
as a town councillor thank you
councillor thank you chairman by
by virtue of being a town councillor
thank you
councilman uh yes it's the same reason
i'm a
rainy town councillor okay council
humbly again
thank you chairman i also need to
declare that interest as a member of
raidertown council's current chairman
i shall um also declare an interest as a
member for raleigh town council
council newport
sorry carol did you speak
councillor newport yeah sorry i can't
get
panned up on my system
i'm the same as the rest of valley town
council
i will note that councillor pavlin thank
you
thank you i'm reading it
yes chairman if i may um i'm aware that
members are declaring the industry
interest but in in this instance here in
this report
there is no need to declare interests um
it's not it's really to do with the
legal documents not anything to do with
the development of
the actual operational side of things
okay so but we are aware we have noted
those thank you
okay did everybody hear that no
didn't you i did
the um there was no need to declare
interests as members of
other councils but that's all been done
now but um
just remember that for future thank you
members
members i shall now take item three on
the
agenda the asset delivery program
contract award
members we have a number of external
partners attending the meeting who will
assist in presenting relevant
information to the meeting
and in answering questions namely
mr duncan blacky of dcb property
kurt hardy of gleads sandy monroe
and richard brooks both of anthony
collins solicitors
and andrew rowelson east of england lga
you're very welcome and also
councillors wooden as a previous
portfolio holder for enterprise and
encounters steptoe is chairman of the
investment board and members of the
asset development program
working group will also assist in
presenting the report
to this meeting councilor simon wooten
leader of the council
will now introduce the report councillor
wootton
chairman good evening and thank you
as leader and with portfolio holding
responsibility for this project
i am delighted to introduce this report
to this extraordinary
meeting of council specifically convened
to deal with the asset delivery program
oxford district council is pursuing an
ambitious
asset strategy with the following
objectives
to reduce ongoing future costs which
will only
increase and must therefore be in the
interest of council tax payers
to regenerate the local area and provide
facilities for local residents
and businesses across the whole of the
rochford district
and to provide fit for purpose office
accommodation
for council staff and key partners in
order to drive
efficiencies through a digital first
way of working the project last came
before members on the 19th of may
when council resolved to appoint gb
partnerships
as the council's preferred bidder
following a comprehensive procurement
process
during the debate that evening members
raised a number of very important points
which needed to be taken into account as
the council moved to the next stage of
the process
which was to negotiate contracts
tonight we are learning how negotiations
have been
progressed for a resolution
chairman this project is member-led
members have been involved in it from
day one
and with your permission chairman a
number of them
wish to speak to this council to talk
about their involvement
before we get down into the detail
and chairman there is a lot of detail
the vast majority of which
is contained within the confidential
appendices to this
report to avoid any difficulties
i would ask please chairman that any
questions be deferred
until the confidential part of this
meeting
so that topics can be discussed freely
as this project originates from the
investment board
with your permission chairman i would
like to call upon councillor mike
strepto as chair of the investment board
to remind members of where we began this
journey
thank you chairman thank you councilwood
and permission granted
a council ascepto thank you chairman
the idea of the use of the freight house
for potential council chamber goes back
many years
uh it was actually first raised as an
item at one of our budget away days by
somebody that has no i'm sadly is no
longer a counselor
once i became a portfolio holder for
enterprise
we started to look into the
possibility of looking at what our
assets and what we could do with our
assets
and as chairman of investment board i've
been pleased to oversee the development
of the council's asset strategy
and the project which has emerged from
that strategy
the investment board has seen this
project evolved
from early strategic case to more
detailed
online business case and then to the
final business case
which the investment board recommended
to the council on the 19th of
the may has been through a comprehensive
process
and has also been a new has been new and
something confu
sometimes confusing process as we've
never
never been involved in competitive
dialogue
procurement before i would suggest a
very steep learning curve
the current progress progress was
reported to the investment board
and we went through various stages and
the member working group
comprised of the investment board
members and myself as chair
have worked closely with the officers
and external professional advisors
throughout
members will recall that one of the
priorities of our business plan
is to maximize our access assets
and when investment board was created
its terms of reference included the
words
to ensure the best use is made of our
sites and property
and that opportunity for co-location has
come
in income generating activities are
explored
maximizing both economic social value
of the district
this project will invest to improve
heritage sites
invest in community facilities in two of
the district's town
centers it will avoid the council taking
on
very high revenue costs which would
otherwise significantly
impact on already stretched budgets
this is an investment to save program
where
doing nothing is simply not an option
german i would like to take this
opportunity to extend my thanks to the
member working group for all of its hard
work over the last few years
i'm sure you would agree i'm sure they
would agree it's been an interesting
experience
i would also like to thank the officers
and the outside
advisors who some of them are with us
tonight
worked with the member working group in
dealing with all the
challenging questions and issues that
were raised
with your permission chairman i would
like to call on councillor
sparring on behalf of the member working
group
to advise members of the work they had
undertaken
thank thank you council steptoe
permission granted
council sparing
thank you chairman and thank you
councillor steptoe
good evening members and visitors when i
first became involved with this project
as part of the member working group i
was unsure
as to what the project was trying to
achieve
and was worried about doing anything
with the council's buildings
and i was definitely very concerned
about moving the council's offices
and chamber i know i wasn't the only one
that had these views
i was however open-minded and wanted to
understand what benefits this project
could bring
not only to the council but also to
residents
and the district as a whole i soon
realized that the freight house
and the art mills and event centre are
tired
and all they are both well-loved and
important community facilities
they are products of their time and
needed to be updated
and certainly are not used to their full
potential
to keep these sites operational to
undertake the work necessary to bring
mutton
more modern standard would have put a
huge financial strain on the council's
budget
and that is just that is just to keep
them running as they are
when we know they are really
underutilized
and thus this is not a good use of
public money
the council offices
and chamber in raleigh are in similar in
need of huge
financial investment and these spaces do
not reflect modern environmental working
areas
for officers or members and definitely
not for residents
for example the public reception area in
south street
is a porter cabin and has been there for
well over 10 years
as this project progressed i became
convinced
that it was right that the council
should invest in the facilities
that the council and our residents
needed and not just keep plowing money
into what we have
however we need you to find the most
cost effective way of doing this
this project allows us to realize funds
from our old buildings
and to cross fund new buildings albeit
with some topping up
to get a great investment not only for
the district
but is also a legacy for our future
the process to get to this point by
councillor steptoe said
was was new to us it was a steep
learning curve
with members of the working group
working closely with officers
and advisors over a very long period
throughout this period we have been able
to ask questions
challenge and think about what was
needed from this project
to achieve the best possible outcome for
both residents
and the council additionally
we have reviewed the comments made by
members during the meeting of the 19th
of may
and did our utmost to ensure concerns
and their views were addressed in full
i want to assure members and residents
all along
that with our partners throughout the
world we have come without the best ways
of achieving the best possible outcome
it isn't just about saving money
it's also about investing in our future
for our district
and our residents
over the last couple of meetings we have
been presented with a number of very
lengthy
and involved legal contracts we know
although we read
them in full representative anthony
collins obviously
support and talked us through the
contracts
and clarified a number of points which
we raised
after this we asked numerous questions
that were generated by these contracts
arranging from the risks involved in
relation to this project
and how we could minimize exposure to
the council
the effects of covid and the new council
working practices
movement in land values both up and down
the financial standing of our partners
environmental standards the adequacy of
our new community facilities
not to him not to mention the impact on
the district as a whole
as far as i'm aware the working group
has now completed the task
for which it was set up and we have
worked closely
with not only officers but our partners
gleads and anthony collins
who both met and exceeded the council's
due diligence review
and both have proven track records of
being able to progress
and fulfill similar projects to which we
are undertaking
and i believe there comes a point where
we as clients of these partners
must trust in their extensive extensive
professional abilities
to produce the best possible outcome on
our behalf
for these reasons we fully support the
proposal being
bringing this proposed item to full
council this evening
with your permission chairman finally
throughout this project the members
working group has been supported by the
east of england local government
association
through a critical friend role
undertaken by mr andrew rowelson
so with your permission chairman i would
ask andrew to talk to members about his
role
thank you council sparring permission
granted
i will now invite mr andrew rowelson
east of england lga to continue with the
presentation
mr elson thank you chairman and thank
you councillor spuring and thank you for
this opportunity to say a few words to
the council meeting
um yes i'm andrew from the east of
england
local government association as
councillor sperring
has said and i've been working with the
council and supporting the council
on this program since very early in 2019
my role is to be what we would call a
critical friend to the council
that is both to members and to officers
and to challenge where necessary to
ensure that best practices followed
and that the council achieves its
objectives
i'd like to make three key points
first i've seen firsthand that the
council has conducted
a very thorough and robust procurement
and your officers and their expert
advisors
have operated in a very professional
manner throughout
which i think is evidenced by the
quality of all the reports and papers
that have been brought before you both
today
and previously secondly
i think the council can be reassured
that the procurement approach
has been very well scrutinized by
members
through the member working group process
i've had the benefit of attending most
of the mwg meetings
so again i've seen firsthand how members
have been very open
and have asked searching questions and
challenged officers when necessary
indeed i very soon learned that the
members here
didn't need much prompting from me
thirdly and finally i think it's been
really noteworthy
and noticeable that it's been and an
all-canceled team effort
yes members have done their job and been
very challenging on occasion
where necessary but at the same time
they have provided the all-important
political steer and leadership on
sensitive issues
such as car parking and
they have also supported and encouraged
the officer team
during what has been a really long and
arduous process
as mentioned made even more difficult
by covid19 over the last few months
so i think tonight you are seeing the
benefit
and result of this team effort
thank you chairman that's all i wanted
to say by way of comments
um it may be that other members from
mbwg
would want to say something at this
point but otherwise back to yourself
thank you thank you mr ralston
um are there any members other members
of the working group who wish to speak
no one is indicating counselor william
yeah thank you chairman um yeah i would
like to thank everybody that's been
involved it's been
i can't believe it's been a couple of
years that we since we started this it's
uh
it's been very interesting um so just
thank you very much for everybody that's
been involved and i look forward to
and would certainly recommend the the
recommendations in this this
meeting this evening thank you all
you're muted chairman sorry thank you
does anybody other other members of the
working group wish to speak
no thank you
i will now open up the meeting the
public meeting to
other members um to debate
and does anybody wish to speak
counselor eves
thank you chair could i just uh make a
point
uh please on one of the things that i
know a number of members have actually
struggled with we've had a massive
document
put before us to actually do our due
diligence
over and we've been given five days to
do that
uh it's accentuated by the fact that um
sonia has actually highlighted a
particular place for us
to read the
point i'm making on that one is that
really to present us
with such a huge document such an
important document
to be able to do due diligence in five
days is uh
is in my view unacceptable however
that aside i'd like to
say the following i have taken a
different approach to the asset delivery
program
to that of some in the minority groups
in that i do understand the benefit of
the project to some degree
but as the only council member who has
qualifications and experience in the
industry at this level
i have had a number of concerns my
comments are based around the freight
house but as the project is set up as
one
the implications of what i have to say
affect the whole project
at the outset of the project members
were presented with a report that made
it very clear
that the project would be much cheaper
if we proceeded with the project
in-house this was decided it was not an
option
as the council did not have the skills
despite my protestations at the time and
assertion that we could bring the skills
in-house
save the council money the project was
pushed ahead
on the basis of a partnership the
majority share of any profit made
being afforded to the developer
lately as a council we have experienced
unexpected
financial pressures as a result of the
kovic 19 pandemic
we've had to use reserve funds to
facilitate the needs
when i spoke to naomi earlier today she
repeated
what we've been told before that she
will not be in a position to know the
full impact
of the last few months on our finances
until the end of the year
this may have an impact on the project
funding we don't know
we are currently being asked to consider
the acela white paper from
central government i know there are
members who are concerned about this for
a number of good reasons
but when considering the asset delivery
program
the project is based on the needs of
this council as it performs now
and in the future but the fact is
that there is likely to be a change in
our operations
if and when the seller project goes
ahead
this has a strong possibility that it
will affect our operational needs when
it happens
the question then is will our brand new
offices be appropriate at the time
the answer is that we simply don't know
i spoke to one of my customers earlier
today he is a director of multi-million
pound company
for full disclosure the company's called
bw limited
they are involved in office building and
refurbishment
mainly in london he is experiencing a
situation in the real world where
companies are holding back on
developments
and asking what does the office of the
future look like
the simple fact in the answer is that
nobody currently knows
his take on anyone who is carrying out
office refurbishment based on current
standards
at this point in time will find that
they are outdated by the time they are
finished
for example how many people you project
to work in a certain space
how many toilets will be required and
will hygiene standards change
facilities within air conditioning will
they have to be updated
refactory areas in relaxation areas will
they
even be appropriate are there enough
conference areas as more people switch
to remote working
all of these facts point to only one
sensible route
in my mind which is to pause the project
until the end
of the third quarter next year when the
thinking and standards for modern
offices going forward
will be much clearer there is a chance
too
that the sl effect on the council may be
clearer by then
our financial position as a council will
also be clearer
i'd like to ask the council how we would
feel if after all this time and money
we end up with a white elephant which is
an infinite
possibility we are told at full council
and the investment board
that we would hold or cancel that we
could hold or cancel the project
any time before contracts are agreed
unsigned this is that point
to proceed further with a project at
this point in time would exhibit a total
lack of understanding for the reality of
the situation in the real world
as it currently is and as such i would
like to propose a motion to pause the
project
until the end of the third quarter next
year to allow for clarity
on what the new working environment and
model will look like
so we can be sure that the vast sums of
public money
that we are potentially looking to spend
are spent wisely
thank you chair thank you councillor
eves
i'd like to second that promotion from
councillors thank you
who was that speaking please that's the
hook way
thank you council hawkway
members um we shall now
debate the motion as uh mentioned
by councillor eve and seconded by
accountant
would anybody like to speak on that
motion please
council mrs mason
thank you mr chairman yes i think
counselor
eaves has very eloquently covered many
areas that we should all be
concerned about members we need to ask
ourselves a question
is this decision being taken prematurely
there are many issues which affect
rochford district council and the
community
it serves that are as yet unknown or
unclear
which should influence this decision
the proposed mergers and creation of
super councils
which a politically led administration
representing the party in government
will be unlikely to prevent has not been
fully considered
and the likelihood of an over provision
of new council offices
in rochford similarly let us be honest
there is no
material difference between the leader's
declared opposition to a merger
as reported in the echo and his apparent
preparedness
to join in my view ask your sales
members
if the loss of income to russia district
council such as car parking and business
rates
or the extra costs for such as
homelessness
consultancy costs that so far this year
run to 626
000 pounds and the costs of covid
arrangements
are yet fully understood or known and
could increase
risk to this council in my view
no realistic figures will be known until
the end of the financial year
ask yourself members if this project has
taken into account
the accelerated rate of changes to our
working from home practices
of course not it's much too early for
that
i believe that this vanity project is
premature
and should be deferred
thank you thank you um
councillor mrs mason does anybody else
wish to speak
on councillor eve's motion councillor
canel
thank you chair uh i just wanted to
to speak on um
the the report uh and then link that
into
uh counselor eve's motion if that's okay
um on page 3.4
item seven the program changes uh one of
the
the um the points rates here is the
introduction of stop go points into the
contracts and i believe this is
to be applauded and i believe um 7.4
is a great example of prudent mitigation
linking that through to the final
business case review on page 3.
3.4 item 3 and the final business case
review contains
uh covered analysis uh and concludes
that the position
of the fbc is actually strengthened
um again the council
point of order are we discussing an
exempt
document
no this is uh thank you counselor or
this is
in relation to the report that's been
provided
not the exempt item the public report
germany are unable to hear you chairman
councilwood uh councillor canal was
referring to the report that's been
presented
i shall allow him to continue but asked
him to
quickly to make his point if he would um
can i ask all members also to take great
care
not to refer to any exempt
information councillor canal
to speak to continue to speak on adrian
their council
thank you chair so the reason i
mentioned that is i had um questions
around whether similar
impacts of the government's upcoming
white paper have been considered
and if we could in in the absence
of voting against the deferment with a
specific date
if we could consider um a similar stop
go approach or review window to assess
the viability
of a new chamber once the future of the
local government structure is understood
and also if we could update the risk
lock
mentioned in item 10 to reflect the
upcoming white paper
there are my two questions chair thank
you thank you
um account canal does anybody else wish
to speak
on council eve's motion please council
chancellor wooden
thank you chairman um appreciate that
opportunity and i note the points that
council reads makes
and i think um if i understood him
correctly
he was referring to a seller in the same
breath as the government white
paper and i think we need to make it
quite clear that
a seller is all about a growth bid that
has been submitted to
central government it is not about local
government reform
which i believe is the white paper that
is due to come out we're told
sometime in october i note the points
that
uh council reeves and others have made
about london development
and indeed that is an issue but i think
we need to get into some perspective
what we're actually talking about in
this program we are talking about
rationalizing our office space and
actually
decreasing the size of our office space
to modern purpose-built fit for purpose
buildings um and those buildings will be
on that building okay when we're
speaking to deferment
to hear you chairman robin
my apologies members counselor mrs mason
i take your point but i shall allow
council wooten to continue
thank you councilwood thank you chairman
and the point that i'm making is in
relation to the reasons why i do not
believe that we should be deferring
the whole point of this project is
actually to quickly get on with a
project
um to streamline our offices make them
fit for purpose
and who could decry uh creating a new
purpose-built community center
in um in raley
there will be an indefinite reason and
use for the public to have these
premises
so whilst there will always be reasons
to defer
i actually think that what we're doing
is considerably ahead
of what other authorities are looking at
and i actually applaud
this initiative and actually the current
pandemic
has become an even more justifiable
reason
not to defer and to get on with this
project thank you very much indeed
chairman
wilson uh council newport
thank you chairman um
you know just um in support of
councillor reeves
um motion to defer um i will just um
reference what councillor woodson just
said about um decreeing
the new um community asset in
rayleigh well unfortunately our
residents haven't had
a say in that matter as there's been no
public consultation
so they haven't had an opportunity to
voice their views on this
they have had an opportunity to voice
their views
on this to their ward councillors
and i've had many many residents contact
me
about their concerns and unfortunately
i've not been out in a position to
reassure them as most of this project
has been in private and confidential the
world
has significantly changed in the last
six months
and the council seems what appears to be
determined to plow on
despite that officers have been working
remotely
and the entire workforce so new numerous
residents have asked me who will be
using the new offices
i personally think it would be reckless
of the council to proceed at this stage
with the project
knowing that within the not too distant
future
could be in a position that a combined
authority could be a likely outcome
and as councillor eve said do these new
offices become a white elephant
i would urge the members to think
carefully about stripping the public
of community facilities and instead take
this moment to pause for thought
will the uncertainty of our future
public finances
and the changes that we are facing with
this
is it really the time to be committing
to such a large-scale
project thank you chairman
thank you councillor newport council
wilson
thank you chairman um just really to
echo the points
uh made by council reeves uh council
newport
and council mrs mason um in the past i
asked the managing director
whether there was any degradation of
service due to staff working at home
um during the corona virus pandemic and
it appears not so if that is the case
i don't understand why we now want to go
full tilt to develop offices which
we haven't actually needed over the last
six months
and i would fully support the deferral
thank you chairman
thank you council wilson council award
thank you chairman um i i don't have
a prepared script as some of the
previous
members have i've been listening you
know to the debate
i i have to i have to say that
deferring this would be a huge mistake
i believe a lot of work has gone into
ensuring that
we've actually got a project that is fit
for the future
i believe it will be a great service
to our residents with regard
to working from home and various other
things that are happening in london and
around
i believe a lot of office space
will become redundant that is true but
we are actually reducing our office
space
we are actually saving a huge amount of
money
on those properties those assets we have
and i think that uh councillor david
sperring made
that very point very strongly we are
paying
a lot of
mr chairman that the subject has gone on
for proposal and not deferment
all right please i am speaking for
against a deferment if you wouldn't mind
councilman mason welcome mrs mason
i shall allow council ward to continue
thank you
thank you very much chairman um i i'm
speaking against
deferment because belief
the premise is open they are not fit for
purpose
we are way ahead of the game of every
other council
in actually recognizing that we need to
scale
down and we need to improve our assets
as with the mill the mill is a very old
asset not fit for purpose
and we'll have a state-of-the-art new
facility there the same as we will have
new facilities for our offices
when we leave south street so i'm sorry
i cannot support deferment in any way
shape or form i think that the uh
assessments that mrs mason councilman
point of order chairman i i'm sorry i
can't hear council award
his audio keeps breaking up
i can hear him okay the council port i'm
sure
it must be i'm sorry uh councillor
newport must be your own wi-fi
um what i can't what i'd like to say is
i totally disagree
with mrs mason's assessment
um of the situation and i think
that i cannot possibly support deferment
at all thank you mr chairman
[Music]
mrs belton
thank you chairman just one point um
against deferment whilst i agree working
from home
is is possible and is an option is it in
all of the staff's best interests to
have that as a permanent option
or a permanent solution probably not
mental health and well-being is
important
and fit for purpose office spaces that
will allow people to work from home
and in the office as they see fit is
surely much
better across the board
thank you council belt and councillor
stanley
thank you chair unfortunately
we don't possess a crystal ball to see
how the future is going to
arrive to us we already know
that uh several uh
premises in raleigh are now going to
close down
and we know that our income
will be less than what it is at the
moment
and we may have to spend a little bit
more money out of our reserves
to continue if this continues
as we see from uh
the the the premises in raleigh
and also uh the flight uh
from uh the airport
uh the firm is now no longer there
or will not be any longer there the the
amount of
money coming in will be drastically
reduced
i do think that as people are working
from home
we have saved an awful lot of money on
our premises
no we let no electricity is being used
or hardly any
no heating it's wonderful news and those
that have got
to have paperwork they go out and buy
their paper and they put it in their
printing machines and so on and so on
unless the
unless we've supplied them with printers
and such like which i
dare say we have in the way of computers
but nevertheless we are still saving an
awful lot of money
now when it comes to spending money like
this
we've had those in the past where we've
spent an awful lot of money
over half a million on one contract
alone and it never got
it never got through it nothing's been
done at all and you know what i mean
it's at south street
there are other projects in the past
that have cost
the
i am speaking on deferment when you make
it perfectly
thank you um i'm speaking on deferment
in the in the fact that i do think we
ought to
sit back for a while
cool down have a have a look at what
we're doing
we are actually selling off the assets
to this council
and there's a lot of money there and the
assets are
don't belong to the council they belong
to the public the public have paid for
it
and we need to we need to sit back and
and
just take a little bit of a breather to
have a
to question what we're doing and whether
we should continue in this light
where we i can't see into a crystal ball
to see what the future's going to be
like at the moment we are dealing with
covet we are dealing with a lot of
factors
and and a lot of businesses easy jets
going down the wall
a lot of businesses i think i think
your point i would agree i would agree
with councillor eves
to defer for a short period of time
thank you thank you councillor hookway
thank you chairman um
there's a there's a number of good
reasons why
i decided to uh second country's motion
um and a number of councillors have
raised the uh the reasoning in their in
their
in number of their arguments um
i do agree with council award in respect
that uh a lot of work has gone into uh
this project a lot of assessment has
taken place about this project
however we are in a different uh
situation now than what a number of
those
assessments and conclusions um have uh
have taken place uh in the past as we've
gone through the process
and bearing in mind that this is a major
project for the council
involves um as uh councillor stanley
said
assets which are basic basically um
public assets
we need to be very careful in how we
how we use those assets um
because if if they're not used
appropriately or
you know we could lose uh that and um
we we would be answerable to um
our public um about uh the reasoning why
we've gone down this route
um it's uh is appropriate just to pause
um and to reflect on on this situation
um even that uh councilor belton's uh
opinion and view about homework and how
uh this affects um our staff
uh is is a is a good point raised but we
don't know
um the the impact of a lot of these
things at this moment in time
and it's another it's another point to
say
surely we we need to just to pause and
reflect
on this and perhaps see uh
where um where we will be
um in in in a few months time
um so i've that's that's one of the
reasons why i support counter eve's um
motion um and i think the councilors
uh should reflect on this and consider
um the uh norm the enormity of uh
what's been asked of us uh this evening
in relation to this
and and as to whether we should think
about this a little bit more thank you
thank you thank you council hawkway
councillor
thank you chairman um deferring achieves
nothing
chairman um and and going on to staff
actually there are many staff that i
spoke to that actually can't wait to get
back into the office because they're fed
up from working from home
um we're also all members we
we may have counsellor in front of our
names but we're all members of the
public
and i for one don't want to keep pumping
money into buildings that are not fit
for purpose thank you
thank you councillor council webb
thank you chairman yes i would like to
speak against deferment as well
um just two two points to me if i may on
that i think the
the concerns that councillor belton
raised um
i agree with that i think staff in terms
of their mental health will be much
better going back to offices when they
can
and certainly that environment will be
um
would be would be good for them but also
in terms of the ongoing redevelopment of
rochford as well
it would be good to see the freight
house back in use again
and that's only going to happen now when
we are able to redevelop that site
so certainly from a community
perspective i'll be very keen to see the
freight house redeveloped as soon as
possible
thank you chairman thank you council web
counselor mrs shaw
thank you chairman i can't agree to
deferment as it's already been
uh stated by uh councillor belton
um it is good to work from home either
i've done that in my work life
but i actually think um the staff need
interaction with each other and it's
essential
that the staff do go back into
offices we um
for the interaction and for their mental
health also
a residence um i've had various
residents ring me speak to me
that they need to see um our officers
um on a one-to-one phase basis
i know our offices are starting to open
because we've got to remember not all of
our residents have zoom
or teams um the they so they
do need to get go into offices and speak
to people so i
ca i will uh i can't sorry i think this
should be
not be deferred thank you
thank you council mrs shaw councillor
efti
here we go again uh chairman same old
argument deferment
this was brought in the first time he's
came to council or the opposition
said we need to defer this deference
because of kovid we don't know what's
going to happen
but we are where we are covet is
happening hopefully we get over this and
people start coming back to offices and
start going back to work
so i cannot support deferment on this we
need to go ahead we need to make a
decision
make a strong decision where we're going
thank you chairman
thank you councillor ft council walls
you've indicated you wish to speak again
but you've already spoken on
uh the motion i won't allow you come to
come back
on that motion um i can't
see anybody else indicating they wish to
speak
so sorry sorry councillor milne you've
just popped up
yes i think i'm uh not in favor of
deferring this program at all because
one thing we seem to lost sight of here
is in the due diligence there was 300
000 a year and losses the way things are
even the current mill was losing i think
it was it 50 to 80
000 so we start talking about this and
the other thing is
what state would the united kingdom be
in if everyone's just sitting indoors at
home we have to make
safe environments and we're learning how
to do that
and this sort of negative thinking about
this this is a
absolutely great value for money program
because when it's all sorted out the
amount
of facility we will get and modern
facilities
for the actual net cost has been quite a
remarkable job so i vote
against deferment thank you councilman
yes thank you chairman sorry i couldn't
get off of mute um
i would have to vote against deferment
uh this is these assets are outdated
we need to be able to move forward
and uh modernize what we do offer our
residents
and our what our mem our staff
so that we can um offer a better
facility for
everyone and an opportunity for
regeneration
in the area and for that reason i cannot
agree with the uh
the motion thank you thank you cancer
gooding
i can see no one else indicate and they
wish to speak on the motion
counselor eaves could i ask you please
to repeat
your motion yeah before i repeat i'd
like to come back on uh
a lot of the points raised please if i
may share uh just briefly
um i think the problem is that a lot of
councillors here have not actually heard
what i've said instead you've just gone
with the party line
what i said is that we need to be
looking at pausing
not stopping pausing now yes
we will if we carry on now have much
much better
offices than we already have but
the point i was making is that working
practices are changing
so drastically and so quickly at the
moment
that if we paused we would have better
offices if we pause because we would
have chance to actually take in new york
working practices
i have spoken to professionals
in this realm um i'm i doubt whether
many other members have actually spoken
to uh members of the level that i've
that
i've spoken to councillor belton's point
about uh working uh remotely etc
there are actually projects on way at
the moment
which are dealing with that but are
still
um moving things on so
the i would urge you to understand
what i'm the reason being why i'm asking
for a pause
is not to stop the project but to
actually
make sure that we end up with a better
project
at the end of the day so to that means
uh to that end
i would like to propose that we
if we pause and that's the word i won't
put in there we pause
the project until the third quarter of
next year
to be able to consider how working
practices
have changed dramatically and the extent
that that will change the
design of what we are looking for in our
new
shiny offices thank you thank you
countless councillor hookway do you
still second that motion
yes um i thank countries for clarifying
his position i understood his position
when he first spoke
and i agree with um his uh explanation
now so i do second it yes
thank you council hawkway our members
i shall put that motion to the vote
and voting will be done by a roll call
of names
please when i call out your name
indicate if you wish to have a recorded
vote
and then whether you are voting for or
against
the recommendation or should you wish
to abstain
recorded vote you didn't say that yes i
did say that councillor eaves
mr reefer you can vote when i call your
name you can vote for a
recorded vote for against or abstain
for your motion thank you councillor mrs
belton
thank you no recorded vote against the
motion
counselor mrs butcher
thank you chairman no recorded vote
against the motion
councillor canal
recorded vote chair um against the
motion
council mr carter
no recorded against council mrs carter
thank you chair recorded vote please and
i'm for the proposal to pause
thank you myself no recorded vote
against the motion councillor fd
thank you chairman nobody called he vote
and against the motion
no recorded vote and against the motion
thank you chairman
thank you councillor hazelwood no
recorded vote and against emotion
councillor hawkway
thank you chairman uh recorded vote and
for the motion thank you
councillor hudson no recorded vote
and against the motion council lucas
gill
he's not with us councillor mrs lumley
no recorded vote and against
council mrs mason
for a recorded vote for the motion
thank you councillor mrs mcpherson
no recorded vote and against the motion
thank you chairman
thank you councilman
no recorded vote and against
councillor mill no recorded vote and
against the motion
council newport
uh full recorded vote
and for the motion and um chairman
can i have my vote recorded in the
minutes if we don't have a recorded vote
please
the answer
no recorded vote and against the motion
thank you
mrs rowe thank you chairman no and
against
thank you councillor mrs shaw thank you
mr chairman
no recording vote and against thank you
council mr shaw no recorded vote
against the motion thank you chairman
thank you council smith
no recorded vote against thank you
council sparing no recorded vote
against council stanley
for a recorded vote and for the motion
and could i have my name on the minutes
please thank you council
a recorded vote against the motion
council award thank you chairman it's
no recorded vote and against the motion
thank you council webb thank you
chairman no recorded vote
and against the motion council mrs
weston
i record your vote and against the
motion thank you chairman
thank you councillor williams thank you
chairman no recorded vote and against
the motion thank you
thank you council wilson thank you
chairman uh for recorded vote
and for the motion and could i have my
name in the minutes of my vote thank you
councilwood thank you chairman
no recorded vote and against
the motion
members um there will be a recorded vote
seven uh members voted for the motion
25 against with no abstentions
so the motions failed
members does anybody else wish to speak
on
item three regards to the presentation
uh made previously bearing in mind
that we are in public session
so you've got council award councillor
award
thank you very much chairman i i do
understand
uh the fact of not coming back before
but um
you know i i do support this this whole
um asset program that's coming through
there were some very interesting points
i have to say that were made in the last
debate
uh the one referring uh to the fact that
we don't have
a crystal ball no we don't and i think
very simply we would have stayed in
caves
uh if we would have been thinking about
crystal ball and not ending up in houses
and in the situation we are now we would
not have made any progress
whatsoever in our civilization you know
in just thinking we don't have a crystal
ball
um i think um one of the comments made
with regard to
reflected and considered i think we have
reflected
and considered everything within
this program and i think you know
the whole concept of us bringing this
forward is really essential
it really really is essential we have to
think for the future
we cannot sit in the past and again this
is coming back to crystal balls no we
don't have a crystal ball we don't know
what's going to happen
per se but we are doing what we consider
to be the best for this council we are
doing
what we think is the best for our
residents and
you know i believe yes we have
considered it very seriously
and i believe that i am fully supportive
of this whole asset program thank you
very much chairman thank you
councillor parkway
thank you chairman um i've um listened
to um what councilwold has just
said um i think he might be going
slightly over the top with some of his
um
analysis but um i just hope that
um with this project that there's
sufficient flexibility in it uh for it
to accommodate any
future changes that may happen um
and um i just also hope that
uh that the money that is going to be
spent on it
is is well spent so um
if uh if people
and councillors and uh the partners
going forward to take into consideration
the concerns
of a number of councillors and hope that
this
uh project is going to be as flexible as
possible
then um then we may have a chance to
bring this to
a positive at the end of the day but i i
for one still have many concerns thank
you thank you council hawkway councillor
fd thank you chairman going to
flexibility has been mentioned a couple
of times
now we have got stop and go decision
points
where we have flexibility things do
change and when it comes to them points
we
decide if we want to carry on if we
don't want to carry on and i applaud
our officers for taking what we said in
the last meeting
and putting these points in there so we
have got stop go
points still we still can change our
mind
we still have got flexibility thank you
thank you councillor fd councillor
whatton
chairman thank you very much indeed i
mean i think the discussion the debate
has been
interesting so far but i think really
it's possibly with your agreement
a time where it would be appropriate to
move into the
detail of the project because there's
some exciting stuff in there
and that includes information contained
in the exempt
appendices thank you councillor woodson
i was about to do that all right um
members um you've all had an opportunity
to speak on the first part of the
presentation for item three
the report contains a number of detailed
exempt appendices in order for the
meeting to be able to discuss any of the
information
set out in these documents we will need
to exclude
the press and the public
i will now move a recommendation under
section 100
a4 the local government act 1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for the following
item of business on the grounds that
involves the likely disclosure of exempt
information is defined in paragraph
three of part one of schedule 12a of the
act
do i have a seconder chairman if i may
can i second that proposal
thank you councillor wooden
uh members voting will be done by roll
call of names when i call out your name
please indicate
if you wish to have a recorded vote and
then whether you wish you of
wish whether you are voting for or
against the recommendation
or if you wish to abstain
councillor mrs belton
no recorded vote for
councillor burton is not with us
councillor mrs butcher
for uh no recorded vote and for the
motion
council canal no recorded vote chair for
the motion
council mrs carter the cancer might come
so counselor mrs carter
yeah yes i thought you wanted to go to
mike first
yeah i'll take you first mr mrs carter
counselor mrs carter
thank you chair um i am recording please
a recorded vote and i'm against
councillor mr carter
no recall did and for
the motion myself no recorded vote and
for the motion
councillor efti
thank you chairman nobody called you
vote and for the motion council
eves recorded vote and fourth motion
councillor gooding thank you chair
no recorded vote and for the motion
council hazelwood
recorded vote and abstain
council hudson no recorded votes and for
the motion
council mrs lumley no recorded vote and
four
thank you council mrs mason
recorded vote of sane
so mrs mcpherson uh no recorded vote and
for the motion
thank you council merrick
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you councillor mail
no recorded vote and for the motion
council newport recorded vote
and abstain council mrs pavlin
no recorded vote and four thank you
thank you
mrs rowe thank you chairman no and four
thank you councillor mrs shaw thank you
chairman
no and four thank you councillor mr shaw
no and four thank you councillor smith
no recorded vote for thank you council
sparing
no and for thank you council stanley
recorded vote and abstain thank you
council steptoe
our recorded vote and for the motion
council award thank you chairman no
and for thank you council webb
thank you chairman no and for
mrs weston no recorded voting for
chairman
thank you councillor williams chairman
uh no recording vote before the motion
council wilson
senior chairman for recorded vote and
abstain
thank you council woodson
thank you chairman no recorded vote and
four
thank you members there will be a
recorded vote
um there were 26 votes for
the motion uh one against and five
abstentions
so that recommendation has been passed
we will now go
uh members into uh private and
confidential
yeah if you can wait a few minutes i'll
confirm
um when we're in private and
confidential